revolution im londoner victoria and
albert museum
es zeigt was die gesellschaft in den
60er jahren um getan hat und uns bis
heute beeinflusst dies ist die letzte
ausstellung des abgetretenen direktors
martin roth und typisch für den
politisch denkenden deutschen sie glaube
dass wir eine kultur unendlich viele
debatten in gang gesetzt haben in den
letzten jahrzehnten die nie entstanden
wären wenn sie nicht in museen
diskutiert worden wären
doch dann kam im juni der schock ein
wahrlich historischer entscheiden
großbritannien stimmt für den bhc rexit
ein nein zu einem offenen vereinten
europa martin roth sorgt daraufhin
selbst für eine kleine revolution
er tritt als museumsdirektor zurück der
grund weshalb ich aufgehört habe
hat er doch jetzt relativ viel ausgelöst
ist ganz bescheiden sich selbst als
beispiel nennen zum einen bringt zumeist
nicht aber ich glaube die debatten die
damit auslösen konnte auch in england
war nicht so schlecht sein rücktritt
stimmte viele nachdenklich doch ist er
nicht auch eine kapitulation
gerade ein museumsdirektor könnte auf
politische veränderung reagieren und
immer mit ausstellung debatten lanciert
ich finde es nicht loyal und nicht
korrekt als deutscher den engländern
spiegel vorzuhalten und sagt so müsste
es machen dass wir nicht nicht
also insofern hierher nach deutschland
zu gehen und zu sagen lasst uns über die
offene gesellschaft reden lasst uns über
pdf den vieles andere zu reden da fühle
ich mich sozusagen berufen oder auch
neujahr meiner eigenen land gegenüber
hab ich kritisch hier nicht mein
gastgeberland das finde ich unanständig
wütende menschen während sich in
deutschland gegen überfremdung genau da
wo martin roth jahrzehnte als direktor
verschiedener museen tätig war
in dresden sein engagement für eine
offene gesellschaft hat nicht die
erhoffte wirkung erzielt
also letztendlich seien jetzt schon
jemand der relativ nüchtern des vor ihm
sitzen weil ich viele jahre und meine
haarfarbe einschließlich dafür
hergegeben habe aus dresden wieder
wieder einen internationalen kultur zu
machen ausgerechnet dort beginnt bei
kida ausgerechnet bis auf die permanent
vertreten ausgerechnet dort ist ein sehr
kleinkariert des fremdenfeindliches
denken bei allem engagement museen
stoßen an grenzen ihrer aufklärungs
kraft sie können zwar brisantes
diskutieren und reflektieren die roads
ausstellung dieser medien top 6 in
london letztes jahr die mit gegenständen
zivilen ungehorsam dokumentiert in
politisch turbulenten zeiten reicht dies
jedoch nicht mehr
jetzt müssen kulturschaffende persönlich
stellung beziehen fordert roth das
museum kann viel aber es kann immer nur
so viel wie die menschen die dahinter
stehen und einem bestimmten punkt müssen
die menschen hinter der bühnen türe
hinter der kulisse hervorkommen sagen
ich stehe dafür als siemens habe ich das
mit mit brett und einigen anderen
versucht also das politische engagement
ist glaube ich momentan mehr gefragt das
persönliche politische engagement ist
mehr gefragt als es institutionelle
alleine eine krasse form weltweit über
lenski der künstler fügt sich schmerzen
zu uns ein anliegen zu
protest gegen das russische region es
werde nicht so ganz der welt nicht gehen
würde
momentan ist alles gut
ich glaube schon dass es fünf vor zwölf
ist oder verlässt nach zehn von zwölf
aber zumindest braucht man eben mehr
allzu lange warten wenn sie noch mehr
zusammen schließt hier in europa mit
europa einfach inland vollen
nationalistische kunden fall bewährt als
ich hätte einfach gerne mehr menschen
die haltung zeigen und farbe bekennen
haltung zeigen
martin roth hat das mit seinem abgang
aus london getan wie er ab jetzt die
massen erreichen will mit seinen
politischen aussagen ist noch offen
eines aber ist klar er wird auch in
zukunft nicht schweigen